y lo hiciste antes no no nunca
si tuvieras que clasificar de frente a
los demás en función de un rasgo
específico qué dirías sobre cómo los ves
y cómo te ven ellos a ti para
averiguarlo reunimos a cinco hombres y
les pedimos que se clasifiquen entre sí
según su fuerza luego los ponemos a
prueba para revelar su fuerza real esta
es la clasificación
cinco hombres se clasifican mayor fuerza
entrando en modo compañeros es un cliché
muy cursi y detesto decirlo hacer
ejercicio como estilo de vida o programa
mi entrenamiento y me digo isaac que
quieres hacer esto bien de acuerdo debo
asegurarme de que no interfiera con mi
tiempo de entrenamiento si diría que es
mi principal afición es algo que esperas
hacer todos los días yo diría que está
entre ejercitarse y jugar que los llevo
a ejercitarse y que los llevó a levantar
pesas empecé a levantar pesas cuando
estaba en secundaria tenía la reputación
de ser el sujeto más grande y seguí
adelante con eso se convirtió en parte
de mi personalidad siempre estuve
involucrado con el deporte en la lucha
libre el fútbol pero empecé a levantar
pesas hace poco tiempo si en el verano
durante octavo grado estuve en una
fiesta en la piscina con mis amigos
saltamos de un lado a otro de la piscina
para pasar el rato y una chica de la que
estaba me dijo edward carga me lanza me
la piscina
la chica me dirigí a la piscina y ella
me dice dios mío edward espera espera yo
le dije que ocurre ella me dice está
temblando mucho no no me siento segura
en dos brazos yo pienso por dios luego
me fui a mi casa
cuando era joven me metí con los juegos
de vídeo y empecé a jugar a la guerra de
las galaxias y a lara croft lo que me
hizo que me metiera en esto fue me
acusaron desde la primaria porque
siempre fui el más grande y más alto y
mis amigos decían isaac eres tan grande
seguro que eres muy muy fuerte y
terminaban lastimando me físicamente
como no sabía qué hacer a medida que
crecía en la secundaria fue cuando pensé
está bien tengo que cambiar así que
empecé a levantar pesas cuando hago
sentadillas compito y levanto pesas es
cuando me sienta empoderado lamento lo
que te pasó porque nadie debería
avergonzarse por su apariencia
los quiero dejarlo claro me voy a
clasificar como el menos fuerte
yo también iré hacia allá
yo no quiero saben que para mí está
entre ustedes dos no tienes mucho
conocimiento sabes mucho y tu motivación
siento que estás por encima de que te
gusta y mira tus cuadros es
las niñas podrías aplastar sandías
hermano es algo genético creo que
debería de ver gente en serio deberías
estar al frente y tú estar de este lado
si quieres ponerme al frente tendrás al
caso tendrás que moverme no poder
hacerlo no de acuerdo creo que está
entre ustedes dos
si hablamos de fuerza bruta masa
muscular genética siento que no estoy
hecho para levantar pesas
literalmente tuve que comer 800 gramos
de carbohidratos al día para llegar a
donde estoy en esta mesa es la cosa te
enfocas ten eso tu vida se usó en eso y
yo no soy hacer el progreso así que
está bien
esto no es para mí saben tengo un
problema con esto la apariencia no lo es
todo ya que tú te ves fuerte pero puede
ser engañoso por eso debemos tener una
clara percepción de lo que estamos
definiendo como fuerza también nos
pondremos a prueba con el peso muerto
así que podríamos clasificarnos de ese
modo muy bien quien creemos que hará
mejor el peso muerto como te sientes ahí
creo que deberíamos quiere decir ayer
tengo el poder bruto y la fuerza que tú
tienes sin la técnica si comparamos eso
siento que cualquiera de ustedes dos es
más fuerte que yo no estoy seguro de es
bueno yo tampoco estoy de acuerdo y él
esté en el medio yo no estoy de acuerdo
no pudiste hacerme amigo creo quizás
deberías seguir siendo el primero y
luego creo que esos dos deberían
cambiarse estoy de acuerdo te puedo
preguntar a qué te dedicas soy militar
eres militancia ya entiendo y tú como yo
soy cartero así que eso está muy bien no
no sé ustedes caminan muchos minutos que
los carteros pueden ser fuertes porque
hay mucho trabajo por hacer como si
fueran muchas cosas pero
del ejército infantería de marina no lo
adivinarás está bien está haciendo bueno
todavía estas drogas elevador debo
buscar extraterrestre sí creo que deben
cambiar sí está bien estoy pensando que
he estado haciendo crossfit desde el año
pasado tal vez tenga una buena técnica
para lo que vamos a hacer
siento que tienes una base muy fuerte se
podrían cambiar pero dos clases
prácticas gira de verlo yo negocio le
pasas pesas sí es por eso pero ingreso
hasta hace poco cierto así es no si
declara puedes hacer una sentadilla un
seguro
y ahora te quiero y yo también lo siento
solo tengo más de un poco no está bien
genial la tuya será de robert él
está bien
se escucha un crujido
[Música]
perfecto tienes una buena base si él
tiene buenas piernas estamos bien
o la gente buena antes de continuar
quiero agradecerle al patrocinador de
este vídeo word be parker word y parker
se compromete a brindarles en línea y
entiendas un cuidado de la vista que
ofrecen anteojos gafas de sol exámenes
de la vista y lentes de contacto les
ofrecen una gran variedad de marcos
elegantes que comienzan por 95 dólares
incluidos los lentes recetados además
también tienen disponibles gafas de sol
progresivas y de luz azul lo que me
gusta de word parker es lo fácil que
puede encontrar el par de anteojos
adecuados después de responder algunas
preguntas en línea word parker les
sugerirá algunos anteojos que se adapten
a su rostro y estilo con su kit de
prueba en casa puede pedir cinco pares
de anteojos y probarse los durante cinco
días sin verse obligado a comprarlos se
envían gratis e incluye una etiqueta de
devolución pre pagada así que es muy
fácil los anteojos son algo muy personal
así que me encanta probarme algunos
padres para ver cuál se ve mejor y
sentirlos antes de comprometerme prueba
gratis cinco pares en word parker
puntocom jubilee ahora disfruta del
episodio
creo que puedo levantar hasta 132 kilos
bien
mientras puedes levantar con una mano
oye perfecto
muy bien vistos
quieres más
eso es
eso no fue un zumo sí sí está bien solo
quiero agregar 5 que es la bien es mi
máximo oye ese es tu récord o lo hice
una vez
vamos por segunda vez
muy bien
bajamos
[Música]
eso arriba
muy bien
gracias a un poco de presión
tú puedes tú puedes
y
eso
no te costó
un poco te lo dije a mí sí
disculpen no sabía que podría hacer muy
bien
152 kilos
vamos
arriba
lo hiciste muy bien muy bien amigo
muy bien crees que podrás hacerlo no
quiero presionar tenemos
cuatro ustedes me hicieron esto
muy bien chicos ya estábamos todos vamos
es fácil
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es un salto de 27 kilos por personales
de 27 kilos nos animamos es gracias los
chicos a todos y eso es es mi turno con
lo que en 5
ya lo hiciste antes no no nunca será mi
récord personal
eso es amigos
vamos vamos vamos arriba arriba arriba
listo vamos arriba
arriba arriba arriba arriba abajo
muy bien muy bien
no sé si es raro decirlo pero tienes la
espalda gruesa la espalda ctp gruesa lo
viste el regreso muerto así es yo se los
dije este tipo tiene mucha fuerza
sinceramente creo que hoy podrás
encontrar más presión que yo mismo
afectada obtiene muchos músculos
es fácil vamos
arriba directo vamos arriba
vamos
bien
son 215 kilos 215 kilos trabajo fácil no
esperaba que él fuera mucho más fuerte
hoy con cinco pesas es mucho peso y nos
hace creer que es fácil es como cargar
el peso de todos hay mucha presión
no pueden ver que puedes pedirle al
equipo de producción que también me
anime
vamos
y si vamos vamos a ver si lo levantas
estoy a punto de rezar ya lo tienes
vamos vamos vamos vamos lo lograrás
jugamos algo duro lo harás vamos arriba
arriba
arriba arriba
vamos vamos
muy bien estaba seguro que lo lograría
me alegro verlo esforzarse eso me da
algo por lo que luchar no he visto a
nadie que levante peso así
fue una divertida experiencia 238 kilos
me sorprende que lo haya levantado mucho
más rápido de lo que pensaba porque no
hice ejercicio en todas las sombras de
lo que hizo
sino en realidad lo que gusta de estar
en forma y hacer ejercicio es que ves a
otras personas y a veces sólo las juzgas
por los grandes que son yo soy grande
pero no puedo levantar tanto peso es un
error creer que los músculos que los
músculos grandes son mejores ya que no
se trata de eso se trata de la pasión y
el tiempo que inviertas en esto para te
así me limita me si bastante bien ahora
tómala por aquí y luego la cosa es que
la barra tiene que tocarte las piernas
cuando las subes arriba sí
tocas las piernas las piernas
completamente rectas
muy bien muchas gracias son 50 dólares